in the lobby of Ramsey solutions that
Dana and Sarah are with us hey guys how
are you
we're doing very well yeah welcome where
are you from Seattle Washington awesome
all the way across the United States to
do your debt free scream I love it how
much have you paid off seventy eight
thousand nine hundred dollars in 20
months killer and how long did that and
what was your range of income during
that time I started that 90 thousand and
currently we're making about 130 cool
what do you guys do for a living I'm an
urban planner mmm-hmm I'm a machinist
very cool good cool what do you what do
you work on what as a machinist I work
for the Navy oh okay
as a contractor or as in the military as
I'm not in the military I'm working for
the Navy gotcha something gotcha cool
it's a civilian that's what I should
have asked okay good very fun what kind
of debt is a 71,000 everything
it got so long that when we first added
it up I think that we thought it was
closer to 19 or 20 but we had to keep
making a new list because we kept
remembering stuff as bills would come no
jewelry furniture anything that somebody
would say yes to giving us we felt
obligated to take out just that kind of
people is just nice fine anybody know so
90 days same as cash or well finance it
press hard there's three copies while
you're signing darling and we'll just
get you on a plan
yes but 90 days same as cash pay over
five years yes yeah it's not the same as
cash I got you okay so furniture jewelry
what else cars a card to pretty much any
store it was um so Lowe's Home Depot
target mm-hmm we had them all yeah sure
full collection we had a big wallet okay
back from sitting on this lumpy wallet
yeah so the student loan debt there was
a tiny bit of student loan debt
that Dana had but luckily luckily /
unluckily most of it was just really
intentional stupid decisions we felt
good about just kind of wandering along
and picking up daisies and here we go
yeah I got you yeah I've done it too I
know how you feel I've done exactly that
I can do that in Costco you know by
myself you know it's just like boom
there you go
it's like federal law you're not
supposed to leave that place without
spending 200 bucks
he never broke the law so what was how
much did you owe on the cars so it was a
combination of so one car was about six
thousand another was about six thousand
we had three and the other one was
seventeen and so on so the vast majority
this was really quite a card in consumer
debt of some kind of another it was so
about maybe 30 days before we were done
on what felt like the longest day we got
a knock at the door and notified of a
debt that neither one of us had known
about that was six years old that was
$15,000 just from a decision that had
been made a long time ago that we didn't
realize had any type of repercussion or
and so it knocked the wind out of our
sails pretty intensely I think we wanted
to take it as a sign that we weren't
supposed to finish this and I just
kicked you in the stomach
yeah just almost there and then you get
kicked yeah yeah but did you got that
clear - every last rain thing is cleared
so you went from and your debt snowball
must have been amazing because you were
paying off something every ten minutes
because there's so many little ones you
had so many mosquitoes flying around you
we really did and a lot of we had
collections also we pulled both of our
reports and had collections that we
started to attack and a lot of them were
really small and so it it really at the
beginning I thought was motivating that
we were able to kill
a handful of them yeah at a time at the
beginning yeah the little ones just
clearing them that was really motivating
yeah it is it's the opposite of the
$15,000 knock at the door yeah yeah this
is what's interesting here is is that
you went from having absolutely no clue
where you are and just buying stuff like
I mean you were like way off the end of
one spectrum and you went all the way
over the other end where you know
everything that's going on and you made
every dollar babe that was a very big
swing emotionally behavior wise
relationally I mean you guys have really
you turned over a new leaf in a real
dramatic way what caused that I'll start
it out um well I got the position to
work for the Navy to to accept that job
I needed to get certain clearances oh
they look at my credit and they're like
you need to fix this because he has to
be like some financial risk yeah okay
yeah you can't get your security
clearance mm-hmm yeah and so I find I
pulled up my credit report which I
hadn't done in many years and it was
full of very bad things mm-hmm and we
work together and using principles that
she had heard on the radio from you
figured out how to pay these bills we
paid them all and I got the job and then
we just went on from there really go we
can do this let's take it a step further
so a little success Brad more success
yeah we took we use some of the
principles to our comfort level
and not that and we paid off a bunch of
that then and that's not actually
included in in the total that we
provided we only included what we did on
the program the way it was supposed to
be done okay um and then we thought well
oh we've never saved money before
independently or together and so then we
thought if we can save money we'll buy a
house and we'll remodel it and and we
did that and as soon as the remodeling
was done is when we started to listen
the podcast more and we're like should
we open up that Pandora's box and look
at what all of those
redick cards from this remodel say and
we did and it was substantially
different than we had thought it was and
we thought well if we could do it some
success using some of it what if we went
all-in and did everything and it was
zero to sixty from that moment dripped
on the gas we lived on less than thirty
seven percent of our income and we said
no to everything I don't know if
anything was it worth it yeah oh man you
feel now great it seems to me what it
seems to me that the debt being gone is
is that is the minor part of your story
it's the change that you two have gone
through I mean you're different people
now we really are like before we started
this I was kind of the person that was
oh we'll just put that on the credit
card cuz I want it now and now we're all
we don't really need that
let's just not buy this I've never
learned to live without before this I
always wanted stuff and then what we
couldn't get it before I felt like I
deserved it and I truly was like I work
so hard like why can't we have these
things and then you said something one
day when I was listening to a podcast
about how what we actually deserve is
peace and freedom and that just really
hit home and as we were going through
this we found out we were pregnant and I
was like I just want stability like no
one to be able to have extreme stability
for a child and well adults devised a
plan and follow what children do what
feels good and you guys have let you
flip the switch yeah now you change your
family tree you did it yeah we did well
done I think that one of the hardest
parts of this though is that we we both
really were so excited about finding out
we were pregnant and I have spent the
last three decades imagining what that
moment would be like and getting to nest
and it was a very difficult decision to
keep saying no to say we need to throw
baby stuff
all right we've got a copy of Chris
Hogan's book for you retire inspired
that's the next chapter for you to be
millionaires and stability for this
beautiful baby here we go Thanks
there we go all right 71,000 paid off in
20 months ninety to a hundred and thirty
Dana and Sarah count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
that is awesomeness right there well
done this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]